There's a movement that is
upending shower routines
across the country.
- There's a new trend in the beauty world.
It's called the No Poo Method.
- The secret could be not shampooing.
Skip the shampoo.
Your hair's better off without it.
At least that's the slogan
for the No Poo Movement
that's got people claiming they haven't
used conventional shampoo in years.
And their hair looks amazing.
But is this just a fad?
What would really happen
if you didn't shampoo
your hair for an entire year?
To find out, we asked
dermatologist Angela J. Lamb, MD,
from Mount Sinai Hospital in New York.
So what shampoos do mostly is they do
what's called saponification.
So the actual shampoo comes along and
wraps around oil and dirt,
and when you rinse, it kinda
comes out with the shampoo.
You kinda rinse out both the
shampoo and the oil and dirt.
But most conventional shampoos
are too good at what they do,
stripping away too much oil
from your hair to the point
where you start producing
extra oil to compensate.
As a result, after the first
few days without using shampoo,
your hair will look and feel
way more oily than normal,
especially if you have straight hair.
So for people that have
straighter-patterned hair,
and like I said, what happens with that
patterned hair is the oils, the sebum,
tend to progress down
the hair shaft faster,
so their hair is going to
feel oilier, dirtier sooner.
After a month of no shampoo,
that oil will have caught a
good amount of dead skin cells,
dirt, and possibly even bacteria,
which could start to make your scalp itchy
and even smell kind of funky.
I would say if you go
longer than about a month,
that you may see some,
again, what you would get
is sometimes odor, you
would get some trapping
of bacteria on your scalp.
After six months to a year,
all that gunk can clog
up your hair follicles,
which can prevent new hair
from growing and, over time,
ultimately lead to hair
thinning or even hair loss.
There's also a risk of
your scalp getting infected
from all the bacterial buildup.
So the signs you want to
look for that would be
problematic that are
telling you you're not
washing your hair often
enough are scale, odor,
sometimes pimples that
lead...that are basically saying
you're getting an infection or bacteria.
Those would be the signs that you would
know that you're not washing often enough.
But here's the thing: rinsing your hair
with gentle cleaning
agents like baking soda
or even just plain
water is often enough to
prevent itching, hair loss, and infection.
So how often should you be rinsing?
So to not wash at all, to use
no water, no cold washing,
no detergent, shampoo, I
think the cut off for how long
you can go really does depend
on your styling pattern.
So many people can do
that for a couple of days,
some people can do it longer,
I would say two to four weeks,
for example if your hair
is locked or if you have
any kind of prosthetic in your
hair like a weave or a braid,
you often can go a little
bit longer just because
of the way the hair is
kind of tied down and
not getting as disrupted.
So if you would like to wash
your hair less frequently,
try to go maybe I'd say about three days
to a week and see how you do.
So you should still wash and rinse,
but you don't have to
repeat every single day.
Just try it out, and see how you do.